wind breaks and shelterbelts have many
benefits
traditionally shelterbelts have been
established for stocked shelter during
extreme weather
following the 2015 primary fire we heard
from our land holders and farmers have
shelter up to native vegetation impacted
on fire behavior and wind patterns
across the odd late rains and lower mid
north on the day of the fire here we we
decided to stay and defend the home
probably right up to the house so since
the fire we've actually started to to
regen and replant I had a look around
them and and really started to study the
trees that actually survived and then I
asked the question why did they survive
and everything else didn't but I'd
really like you oughta ask questions
it's designed around shelterbelts but a
lot of your plantings may be for shade
for making you feel better for your
gardens for reefs or or natural bush so
just ask today we're going to discuss
the most important issues about shelter
belt planting and in reality that's good
planning and think about your property
as a whole and what do you want to
achieve into the future shelter belts
have many benefits they can provide
biodiversity they can provide fantastic
bird habitat they can Harbor insects
that will attack the pests in your crops
you'll get higher wall growths from
sheltered sheep dairy cows have
definitely shown an increase in milk
production if they're not so cold crops
will increase near the shelter belts and
you decrease the evaporation across the
paddock the shelter belts decrease the
wind speeds and therefore your erosion
reduces
total votes should be placed at right
angles to the prevailing winds make sure
that you don't have too many gaps you
can get wind tunneling you can get
increase velocities so if you can't
place a gate at the end of a windbreak
you may need to redesign the ends of
those wind breaks to decrease that
impact of the tunneling wind if you have
a solid wall of trees it acts like a
brick wall the wind will hit it go up
over the top and cause turbulence on the
other side so that becomes a bigger
problem than what you had before you had
the trees if you're going to have a very
simple shelter belt you need to be
permeable or the wind needs to go
through it so that decreases the speed
of the wind and less turbulence all the
way through the composition of a
shoulder belt should include small
shrubs on the outside rows slowly
building up to the largest tree row in
the center five rows wide
the species that you would be planting
usually local species that have the
right form for the position in the
shelter belt it could be you clipped or
a sea oak and a various perm abilities
but in general the outside rows and a
closely planted bushy shrubs this one's
a KC pendulum and I got about 15 trees
that I specifically went in God if you
can't use local species you can't get
enough height look for a plant that will
do the job but won't become a weed the
dry land
tea tree or the Melaleuca prevented fire
in and around our farm and our farm
buildings and another in another
location at least a year Allah hair do
you need to look at ripping your land
starting your week control and ordering
your plants ripping means that you can
get good subsoil moisture and a lot of
root development once you've planted
your trees you need to make sure that
you have air pockets taken out of that
rip line so that's why it's important to
have a year ahead in this region and the
agricultural areas of South Australia
it's really beneficial to plant before
the break of the season in April or
autumn the reason is that the soil still
warm and you can water before the break
and those trees will get roots into the
ground and get established before it
gets too cold to grow that means that
when it starts to dry out in the
following summer they're less needy of
water and so the planting and this
planting was the first planting after
the fire winning on irrigation in about
February last year plants came from the
Barossa Bush gardens and so the
prosperous garden supplied all of the
plants from here shelterbelts are a big
investment on a property but there are
wonderful compromise for planting they
provide so many benefits for the
property the habitat for animals and
birds and reptiles it's well worth
looking at putting in shelterbelts
you'll be better off in your bank
balance and the environment will be
better off in the long run in 2016 and
2017 land holders were given free native
plants tree guards and stakes to help
rebuild native vegetation across the
fire scar okay Chris what was your aim
was it to get height through here yeah
I'm trying to get a bit of height in
here particularly with like with this
sort of that's a commercial interest we
have a red gum type quite a tall tree
quite a big bit of structure coming off
the edges and there's a mix between that
and the saya she act that I've got here
and a pendulum which is a nice sort of
taller tree here
what I'm really just trying to get that
sort of structure in there in the actual
windbreak and help that develop and
using your Melaleuca as a really good
wind barrier which you saw was
successful in the fire yeah interfering
the flow to fire certainly the Melaleuca
that once it rubs up formed a quite a
nice break in other areas so we're
pretty keen to sort of see that clunk
and come back in hopefully we never see
another Pinery but we just want to make
sure that if we are planning and
planting trees we're planning and
planning for the next potential event if
you would like to learn more about
shelterbelts
natural resources adlai Mount Lofty
ranges greeny Australia and their
barossa Busch Gardens are great sources
of information and support
for more information about how we can
support you please head to our website
you
[Music]